hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into
practice I've studied and taught
Philosophy for over 20 years and I find
that many people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured but the
concepts themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them
useful what you're currently watching is
part of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on One Core concept
from an important philosophical text I
hope you find it useful as
well one key theme that you'll see being
brought up over and over again within
Lev chest's early work all things are
possible is the connection ction between
what he calls positivism and we'll talk
about what that means in this case in
just a minute and the broader field of
metaphysics which would include not just
the field itself but particular theories
in it and usually positivism has
understood itself and been understood by
those interpreting it as being
antimetaphysical
shof wants to suggests to us that things
are not quite so simple as it
seems and first we need to get clear
about well what is positivism in part
because if you had an introduction to
philosophy class or you've been looking
around in the history of philosophy
there is a tendency to confound
positivism in the broad sense with a
particular movement in philosophy in the
20th century called logical positivism
which is arising and becoming prominent
after shestov has published this so he's
not targeting AJ air or the early vien
Stein or the Vienna Circle he's
targeting something that's a broader
social and political and intellectual
movement that goes back quite a bit
further indeed so far back that he
identifies uh a particular thinker voler
as having some positivist aspects even
though it's before the term is coined
and we typically associate it with compt
and so we're talking about you know mid
19th century onward and so what is
positivism in in short you can say that
it's a philosophical approach that says
that we should focus on the positive not
positive thinking as in always look on
the bright side or anything like that
but rather what we can actually know and
build out from that we should leave
theology we should leave metaphysics
behind and focus on what we can have
genuine knowledge of so what does that
translate into here's where a remark of
shesto a very short one uh number s 4 in
the first part he says philosophy has
always loved to occupy the position of a
servant in the Middle Ages she was the
handmade of theology nowadays she waits
on science and he notes a kind of
inconsistency here that will
characterize positivism of his time but
also later forms of it at the same time
she calls herself the science
of Sciences and so you know this is a
great remark right it notes that
philosophy quite often uh sets itself
above all the others but at the same
time wants to be subservient and if
we're leaving behind theology we're
leaving behind something else what can
take its place as the master or set of
Masters well some notion of positive
science
it could be the Natural Sciences plus
mathematics plus as com said sociology
and psychology right it can be whatever
it is you want and you see this tendency
over and over and over again arising
Even in our time now Shoff thinks that
positivism which sort of frames itself
as like the most upto-date approach in
philosophy it's leaving behind all of
this nonsense and silly of metaphysics
let alone you know God talk and theology
he's pointing out that well actually
it's kind of connected to metaphysics
but before we get into that let's talk
about
positivism and we could say human
desires and needs so the first remark
that we want to look at is in chapter
n he tells us we know nothing of the
ultimate realities of our existence nor
shall we ever know anything let that be
agreed but because of this it doesn't
follow we must accept some or other
dogmatic Theory as a modus vendi as a
way of living this uh inability of us to
get to the ultimate you know reality uh
to get to a fully satisfying answer
doesn't mean that we have to jump into
some sort of ism and he notes no not
even
positivism which has such a skeptical
face on it it's not really skeptical
though it's in in reality very devoted
to a kind of Dogma or set of dogmas of
its own and so he goes on and says it
only follows that man is free to change
his conception of the universe as often
as he changes his boots or his gloves
and that constancy of principle belongs
only to one's relationships with other
people so that
they may know where and to what extent
they may depend on us on principle man
should respect order in the external
world complete chaos in the inner and
for those who find it difficult to Bear
such a duality some internal order might
be provided only they should not Pride
themselves on it but always remember
it's a sign of their weakness pettiness
dullness so he's rejecting positivism
just as much as he's rejecting
traditional metaphysics that positivism
places itself self as a contender
against if we go on to chapter uh 98
there's an even more pessimistic uh
point of view that's that's expressed
here he says
that in order merely to preserve our
existence we have to strain mind and
body to the utmost he goes on he says
there's no time to think about truth
this is why positivism was invented with
its Theory of natural development now
what is this theory of natural
development that he's talking about you
know it takes place through history with
human beings originally focusing on the
gods and that was actually you know
madeup stuff that they were projecting
out there and then they got away from
the gods and theology into a
metaphysical point of view that was
driven by philosophy right but even that
needs to be left behind and now we can
move on to these sciences and really get
to the bottom of things and uh Shoff is
suggesting here that he says everything
we see is mysterious and
incomprehensible right philosophy has
ever pushed aside to make room for the
daily needs so how does the pursuit of
science really work itself out is it
going to yield us truths absolute truths
probably not he's rather pessimistic
about it and then he has something very
interesting to say about his own times
and I think this is something that we
can see repeated over and over again
from generation to
generation so he says in recent years
this is in in uh section 35 of of part
two we see more and more change in the
philosophies of writers and even
non-literary people the old men are
beside themselves such shiftiness seems
indecent con convictions are not gloves
yeah but the young carelessly passed
from one idea to another and so he he
goes on and says that you know people go
from ISM to ISM and they seem to abandon
you know whatever it was they were
committed to six months ago and he says
that um the Readiness to leave off one
set of convictions in order to ass
assume another shows complete
indifference to convictions alog
together and he says to um you know lot
of people this seems really bad but to
all those of us who fought long against
all kinds of constancy the levity of the
young is a pleasant sight now notice
what he says next they will on
materialism positivism consis
spiritualism and so on one after the
other till they realize that all
theories ideals and ideas are as of
little consequence as the hoop skirts
and krines of our grandmothers
they will begin to live without ideals
and pre-arranged
purposes without foresight relying on
chance and their own ready wit this way
too must be tried perhaps we shall do
better by it anyhow it will be more
fun shof is noting that this is always a
possibility for us we can always jump
from ISM to ISM to ISM we are free as
human beings to decide what convictions
we are going to follow and it seems that
in his time at least in his place where
he's observing younger people are doing
this and older people are getting quite
upset about it right so
positivism instead of becoming the end
of philosophical development becomes one
more possibility one more stage if we
want to use the positivist own schema
for understanding history now we should
talk about the connection that
positivism actually does bear to
metaphysics He's Got This brilliant
remark here with a wonderful artistic
metaphor in Chapter 13 of part one he
says on the whole there's little to
choose between metaphysics and
positivism in each there is the same
Horizon but the composition and coloring
are different now is does positivism
come out on top in this way no why
positivism chooses gray colorless paint
an ordinary composition metaphysics
prefers brilliant coloring and
complicated design and always cares the
vision away into the infinite in which
trick it often succeeds owing to its
skill in perspective now you could say
well the good thing about positivism is
that it's much more realistic it's not
leading us off into these Horizons that
we can't get into to much like you know
when you watch cartoons very famously
the Road Runner and while E coyote uh
you know a a tunnel will be painted and
it's a painted Tunnel right you can't
actually enter it but the Road Runner
does and then the coyote tries to run
after him and boom he hits the wall
because it's just a painted tunnel he
well we shouldn't live in this world of
fancies if things happen happen to be
gray instead of you know
multicolored well that's reality now
notice what chesto says
next he says the canvas is impervious
there's melt no melting through into the
other world nevertheless skillful
perspectives are very alerting so that
metaphysicians will still have something
to quarrel about with the positivist
neither the positivist nor the
metaphysicians actually get to the
canvas itself neither of them are
providing us with what we actually want
the Met Physicians seem to be doing so
but you know to use the metaphor of the
Roadrunner they are more wild E coyote
than anything else he talks as I
mentioned before about voltaire's
positivism uh very briefly and this is
in uh chapter uh
41 of that he says that this is in a
chapter called metaphysical consolations
right
says that the the more that you pierce
to the ultimate ends of the infinite
metaphysical problems the more finite
they reveal themselves metaphysicians
only look out for some new Boon I nearly
said pleasure voler said if there was no
God he should be invented we explain
these words by the great Frenchman's
extreme positivism now we should pause
on that for a moment what about
positivism would tell you that voler
think thinking that uh if there is no
God he should be invented you know is is
an example of this well col's own
positivism took religion and tried to
bring it up to date tried to have a
church of humanity right so positivism
often has metaphysical and even
religious aspirations but then he goes
on and says the form only is positive
the content is purely
metaphysical all that a met
metaphysician wants to do is convince
himself that God exists right so voler
seemingly a positivist is just as much a
metaphysician as the people that he
wants to criticize right and then
finally in uh chapter 4 of part two we
get this very interesting discussion
about what what is it that
metaphysicians are doing and why they
should be called as he says the
positivists par exas showing us a thread
that connects the two of them together
what is it he says metaphysicians praise
the transcendental and carefully avoid
it nature on the other hand hated
metaphysics and always lived in the
realm of the transcendental and he says
of course the metaphysicians behave
better this is indisputable and then he
says in these anxious days when
positivism seems to fall short one
cannot do better than to turn to
metaphysics so you know with the
assistance of a few books the whole
Mysterious Universe is conquered
metaphysics he says is the great art of
swerving round dangerous experience and
this is why they should be called the
positivists par Excellence because what
are the positivist doing you know we're
not going to deal with this this is too
you know uh vague uh this this is
stemming from from some irrational
origin we're only going to focus on
what's right in front of us so he says
um they do not despise all experience
but only the dangerous experiences n on
the other hand is somebody who didn't
avoid dangerous experiences right and so
he says that in order to love the
transcendental it should be known only
from the stage or from the books of the
philosophers at a nice distance right
this is called idealism
the nicest word ever invented by
philosophizing men so again shest is
drawing this connection between
metaphysics and positivism and saying
they're not really that far
apart uh then we get this really
interesting long discussion in chapter
17 of of part two which Begins by
talking about Kant now in our time Kant
is probably less important you know he's
important for moral theory but there's
not an awful lot of conscience out there
I would say in epistomology and
metaphysics but in shestov's time the
effects of Kant and his critique of pure
reason and his uh uh analysis of
metaphysics um was pretty you know of
the present so he says ever since Kant
succeeded in convincing the learned
that the world of phenomena is quite
other than the world of true reality and
that even our own existence is not our
real existence but only the visible
manifestations of a mysterious unknown
substance philosophy has been stuck in a
new rut and cannot move a single
millimeter out of the track laid by the
great kig bergian backward or forward it
can go but necessarily in the consan Rut
Kant has established a new par Paradigm
we might say is it a good Paradigm is it
a satisfying Paradigm he says no it it
definitely isn't surely
the uh the contraposition between the
world of phenomena and the thing is
itself he says is an invention of the
reasoning mind as is the theory of
knowledge there a kentus l to use the
term that was circulating around um
deduced from this
contos so the Freedom loving Spirit
could maybe reject this right and so
we're going to talk about
metaphysics and
absurdity he says that if you grant
reason one single assumption then uh it
is going to place you in its toils right
in in the the the Trap or net and he
says metaphysics cannot exist side by
side with reason everything metaphysical
is
absurd everything reasonable is positive
so sometimes when we think we're doing
metaphysics looking at systems of
metaphysics it's really positivism of a
different sort that we're engaged with
so he goes on and he says the
fundamental principle of metaphysics is
absurdity and yet surely many positive
assertions can lay legitimate claim to
that selfsame highly respective
predicate is there a means of
distinguishing a metaphysical absurdity
from a perfectly ordinary one and he
says uh no all services rendered by
reason must be paid for sooner or later
at the exorbitant price of
self-renunciation renouncing your own
freedom to think about things to take
stances on things and so he tells us
that sooner or later you are are driven
into as he calls it the streets of
positivism and he says this happens all
the time with young inexperienced Minds
what do they do first they break the
bridal and dash forward into space
they're doing some sort of you know uh
study some sort of metaphysics they're
feeling their freedom they're like this
is amazing stuff and then what happens
turns out that the
originality that they feel themselves uh
pursuing inhabit Ed by isn't really that
original uh chest says um they find
themselves rushing into the same old
Rome whether as we know all roads lead
or to use more lofty language rushing
into the stable wither all roads leave
and then he says this is basically a
type of positivism but then He suggests
to us a way to avoid this now it's based
on on an assumption which he's perfectly
happy to say not everybody will buy into
so he says the only way to guard against
positivism granting of course that
positivism no longer attracts your
sympathies so if positivism still does
attract your sympathies this is not
going to be helpful or effective for you
but if you gotten sick of positivism in
part maybe because you realized the
close Affinity it has with the very
metaphysics it claims to
reject well then you have another
option what is it to cease to fear any
absurdities whether rational positive or
metaphysical and systematically to
reject all the services of reason he
says such Behavior has been known in
philosophy and I make bold to recommend
it kredo Quia absurdum comes from the
Middle Ages this is the
famous statement often attributed as
like his summary to tertullian obviously
tertullian wrote a lot more than just
simply that line but it you know it is a
a Viewpoint right I believe because it
is absurd and he says Where can we find
modern examples of this and he brings up
somebody who we talked about already
friederick NAA and then he talks about
Arthur schopenhauer what do they do both
present Noble examples of indifference
to logic and Common Sense and then he
says especially schopenhauer look at him
as a model he is a consan who even in
the name of Kant made such daring
sallies against reason driving her into
confusion and shame that astounding
conscient even went so far in the
master's name still as to attempt the
overthrow of space and time Notions
right he talks about Clairvoyance he
talks about music uh the pracy of will
over reason right and so he goes on
quite a bit about schopenhauer here and
you know he's he's going to close in
part by talking about something that's
available to us in his time and in
ours he tells us there will come a time
when this unshakable Foundation of
positive is M will be shaken all
nosological disputes as to what thought
can or cannot achieve will seem to our
posterity just as amusing as the
disputes of schoolmen seem to
us we don't have to be bound by this
contrast either metaphysics or
positivism we can go beyond both of them
if we so choose if that's
our desire there's no promise that it
will automatically bear fruit for us or
that people will like us as a result or
will become the next next great
philosopher or anything like that but it
is possible to go beyond metaphysics and
positivism according to
shof